[Applause]
[Music]
that's it the conflict is all on again
no matter which month or year it is when
you're hearing this phrase it's almost
always in the news the
israeli-palestinian conflict is like the
ultimate never-ending story a story with
many players a lot of complexities and a
story that has been on a continuous loop
since the creation of the state of
israel
back in 1948. more than 70 years have
passed
and we are still in the same situation
while it is true that israel's relations
with the arab countries are improving at
a rapid pace
on the palestinian issue things are
still as tense and deadlocked as ever
the territory encompassing israel which
comprises 23
of the former british mandate of
palestine has been divided and redivided
again and again giving rise to a complex
map of jewish majority
and muslim-majority enclaves with little
cohesion between them this lack of
territorial cohesion
also fuels complexity at the political
and social level especially in the parts
currently controlled by the arab
palestinians the west bank and the gaza
shrip and the gaza strip
is the clear protagonist of this video
in 2005 following the completion of the
israeli disengagement plan promoted by
then prime minister ariel sharon which
involved incidentally the withdrawal of
troops military posts and the
dismantling of 21 israeli civilian
settlements
gaza managed to administer itself
independently after decades of being
under the control
first of egypt and then of israel
initially the hamas group
formed a unity government with fatah the
major palestinian political party an
agreement that collapsed just a year
later since then the relationship
between fatah and hamas has gone from
bad to worse among other reasons because
both claim control over the territories
controlled by the other side between
2006 and 2011 alone there were
situations of real war between the two
factions in the streets of gaza
shootings
armed clashes the lynching of leaders
and supporters targeted assassinations
kidnappings it is estimated that the
conflict claimed the lives of more than
one thousand palestinians
the fact is that the pieces of land
ended up being shared out basically
hamas was left with political and
military control of the gaza strip while
fatah took control of the west bank but
that wasn't the only problem after the
rapture between the two
the terrorist group hamas of jihadist
and anti-zionist ideology
started a war against israel which
fattar did not support
since then hamas has been carrying out
relatively frequent rocket launches and
kidnapping attempts among other
operations
therefore in order to contextualize what
we're going to tell you in this video
it's important to keep in mind that it
is hamas
from gaza which is practically at war
with israel not fatah which is the group
that controls the palestinian national
authority and most of the palestinian
territory and population
then in addition to hamas we also have
the palestinian islamic jihad another
terrorist group that also fires rockets
into israel from gaza
and sometimes even from the west bank
and then there's the iranian-funded
shiite group hezbollah which
also occasionally fires rockets and
missiles at israeli soil from southern
lebanon
[Music]
so you can imagine that in an area as
populated as the israeli coast with a
group like hamas controlling a territory
of 365 square kilometers and more than
two million inhabitants and others like
islamic jihad or hezbollah also
operating in the area
it becomes vital indispensable priority
number one for israel's security forces
to develop advanced
defense systems
[Music]
because in this case we're not talking
about a game nor a potential threat
but a reality without all these advanced
systems the situation would be
practically
one of permanent war and with all of
them hamas islamic jihad and hezbollah
frequently launching armed projectiles
against israel perhaps the most
important system or at least the most
important in recent times is what is
known as the iron dome would you like to
know more about what is probably the
most advanced missile shield in the
world what it consists of how it works
and what it protects against well listen
up
rocket rain
i'll put it bluntly the iron dome is a
true marvel of military technology for
example it's capable of intercepting 90
of the rockets launched from gaza by
hamas and palestinian islamic jihad
which believe me
is no easy task
the vast majority of the rockets
currently used by these organizations
have a range of less than 100 kilometers
and measure from less than one meter
long to a maximum of about three meters
we're talking for example about the
qassam rockets the syrian made khaibar
m302 or the iranian fajr five rockets
that hamas is believed to be able to
manufacture in gaza thanks to the
transfer of technology from iran but
there are less powerful ones that have a
range of barely two kilometers and are
about 90 centimeters in length they are
very
very small targets to find and destroy
in general these rockets do not have
advanced technology since they do not
even have guidance systems which does
not allow them to
be even called rockets so
what exactly do these attacks look like
how are these rockets launched
well the truth is is that it's not the
most advanced technology in the world
in fact the way to operate them is very
simple the rockets are placed on a
launch pad and the launch inclination
and the amount of fuel required are
calculated according to the target
for example if they want to attack tel
aviv about 70 kilometers away they will
need a higher angle and more fuel than
if they want to attack ashkelon which is
only about 20 kilometers from gaza now
what is the biggest problem the
differential fact that makes these
rockets really dangerous
well basically neither hamas nor islamic
jihad nor israel nor anybody else
knows exactly where the hell they are
going to land in other words these
rockets are
totally random they could either land in
a wheat field or end up embedded against
a civilian residential building and that
is precisely the iron dome's mission to
prevent those rockets from hitting the
ground something that on the other hand
also
saves a lot of economic damage in israel
take a look at this graph in it you can
see the comparison between two years
2006 and 2014 in which a similar number
of rockets were launched against israel
first by hezbollah in 2006 and later by
hamas in 2014
[Music]
in 2006 when the iron dome was not yet
in place
damage costs amounted to 195 million
dollars
in 2014 with dome already in place
damages excluding system costs amounted
to 29 million
even if we calculate the cost of missile
shield operations the bill to be paid in
2014 would amount to 111 million dollars
about 80 million dollars less than the
damage caused by hezbollah in 2006 alone
of course this is not the most important
thing
obviously the most important thing is
how to reduce the risk that one of these
rockets or missiles ends up embedded in
a residential neighborhood or an office
town
by the way a side note here according to
international law firing rockets at will
against civilians is a war crime and yes
i know that in this type of scenario it
is difficult to conveniently gauge the
responsibility of each party but beyond
the consequences or the reaction to them
with which you may agree to a greater or
lesser extent
launching rockets and missiles
indiscriminately is not only a serious
aggression but also a war crime i say
this because many journalists forget
this point
but back to the subject did you know
that between just may 10th
and 13th in 2021 israel was attacked by
more than 1300 rockets
[Music]
[Applause]
it was the largest rocket attack in the
history of the arab israeli conflict and
it is also the occasion where the iron
dome
has been pushed to its limits the most
just look at the numbers of those 1300
rockets only about 200
managed to fall on israeli soil and
another 200 or so
would have fallen into gaza itself due
to launching failures
this means that the iron dome must have
destroyed about 900 rockets
in three days and here's an important
detail right here is when many people
claim that the rocket launching is not
serious because
well let's see in the end they're not
going to land but then why does hamas
launch hundreds
and hundreds thousands of rockets on
israel well precisely because of the
effectiveness of the iron dome hamas
knows that if it wants any of its
rockets to hit israel what it has to do
is launch salvos of many
many rockets at the same time to try to
saturate the capacity of the system
so it's not that they're harmless
fireworks but wait there's more i'm sure
by now you're all wondering
how on earth this dome actually works
what detection systems does it use
how much did it cost to set it up how
much does it cost to operate well let's
take a closer look
[Music]
the shield that protects israel
the iron dome was installed and put into
operation in 2011. the reason for its
development was none other than the
increased frequency and sophistication
of rocket attacks launched by hamas and
hezbollah on israel between 2000 and
2010. and based on experience
it wasn't a bad idea it is estimated
that the system has intercepted more
than three thousand rockets and counting
it was developed by raphael advanced
defense systems and
israel aerospace industries two public
companies of the israeli aerospace and
military
industry it is probably the greatest
work of the israeli military industry
the flagship the jewel in the crown
and of course as you can imagine it
didn't come cheap the israeli government
has spent an estimated 100 million
dollars on each battery or sub unit
in the system and they currently have 10
in service with plans to increase that
count
to 15. in other words we're talking
about a system costing at least
one billion dollars but how does it work
well this image may help you to
visualize it
[Music]
each battery consists of three to four
launchers each equipped with 20 tamiya
guided missiles then other fundamental
elements are the elm
2084 radars and the bmc the battle
management and control system the three
elements that is the launchers
radar and control system make this whole
system work
basically what the radar does is detect
threats usually in the form of rockets
or even drones and then the bmc
orders the launchers to launch guided
missiles whose mission it is to destroy
the threat
in the air the system is generally
designed for a single tamil missile to
destroy a threat although there are
times when more than one is needed to
reach the target
[Applause]
to give you an idea each tamiya missile
costs between twenty thousand dollars
and one hundred thousand dollars
although the consensus figure is around
fifty thousand per unit in other words
to repel an attack
like the one in the second week of may
2021 with at least 1300 rockets launched
against israel it would cost at least 55
million dollars in tamar missiles alone
[Music]
in terms of range each battery can
defend an area of about 150 square
kilometers and has a range of about 70
kilometers in other words a single
battery is capable of completely
protecting a medium-sized city
that is the main reason why there are 10
batteries currently deployed and then
they're looking at having 15. the high
cost of each battery explains why the
iron dome is only deployed in populated
areas
in addition the iron dome has another
benefit it buys time
see for yourself take a look at this map
an israeli living next to the gaza strip
only has
15 seconds to take shelter in a bunker
if an attack occurs
this time increases to about 30 seconds
if you live in ashkelon 45 seconds in
ashdod and about 90 seconds in tel aviv
or jerusalem that means in the time that
you took to listen to this estimate you
should have already gotten into a
shelter
if you lived in ashkelon and heard the
siren and of course in the end
what the im dome does is not only
intercept and destroy nine out of ten
threats but it also allows people a
greater margin to get to shelter
in a safe place it is like a kind of
guardian angel or a soccer goalkeeper
who operates in the sky and tries to
keep the balls from hitting your house
or your business
of course in this case we're not talking
much about balls but about something
much more dangerous
and so this is how the modern system
that protects israel skies morning noon
and night works but having reached this
point
it's your turn what do you think of the
iron dome do you think its high level of
effectiveness could make israel's
enemies switch from rocket fire to
another type of threat as always we love
to hear from you so don't hesitate to
leave us your opinion in the comments
down below and of course if you found
the video interesting don't forget to
like it
and subscribe to visualpolitik all the
best see you in the next one